The SCP Foundation has encountered and contained
some of the most fearsome entities in human
history, and even some from long before us shaved
apes were ever walking across the Earth. They’ve
gotten their hands on ancient gods, humanoid
creatures with deadly powers, and more than one
item with the capacity to bring about the end of
the world as we know it. But not everything at the
SCP Foundation can kill you or would even want to!
Sometimes, an SCP has no agenda other than going
about their lives, making friends, or even helping
people. Instead of wanting to eat you for dinner,
these entities would rather sit down for a meal
and a chat with you. No apocalyptic ambitions
here, just good vibes. Today, we’re taking a
look at some of the friendliest SCPs of all time.
First off is an SCP that’s just as sweet as
it is sad. If you ever encounter SCP-4999,
you probably don’t have long left to live.
That’s not because it’s going to kill you,
or even hurt you, but because 4999 visits
people who are already at death’s door.
Manifesting as a humanoid figure dressed in dark
clothing, SCP-4999 appears to a person about
20 minutes before their death, as long as the
subject is awake and alone. It will then sit down
near their bed, and offer them a cigarette. It
will then light one for itself, and, as it smokes,
hold the dying person’s hand or place a comforting
hand on their shoulder. It will stay there with
them, providing a silent sense of peace, until
they have slipped away. It may not be friendly
in the most traditional sense, but SCP-4999
displays a great deal of kindness and compassion
in making sure that no one ever dies alone.
Though some of the friendliest SCPs are serious,
others are quite silly.
This is the case for SCP-2991. The entity is a
striped, multi-colored scarf capable of changing
lengths. The scarf appears to be sentient,
and behaves in a docile manner, communicating
by forming itself into the shape of letters and
spelling out words. The scarf enjoys attention and
becomes bored if left in its containment box for
too long, and has expressed a desire to play.
When asked if it was “made to be fun,”
the scarf responded “yes,” and then wrapped itself
around the interviewer’s hand and went to sleep.
It does not seem to have any interests other than
playing and spending time wrapped around people,
keeping them warm and cozy. It’s basically
just an ordinary scarf, except it is able to
move on its own and desires the company of
humans. Sounds pretty darn friendly to us.
Some SCPs are perfectly nice, friendly
people who have no control over their
own anomalous properties, and would
probably prefer to just live out a
mundane existence free from any unusual activity.
Unfortunately, you don’t always get what you want,
and neither does SCP-507. 507 is, for all
intents and purposes, an ordinary human man,
with one notable exception. Against his will, he
routinely finds himself teleported into alternate
dimensions, appearing in them and returning to his
original one seemingly at random. Aside from these
odd, stressful occurrences, 507 is a jovial
individual who enjoys meeting other SCPs and
chatting with researchers at the Foundation about
the paranormal. Aside from his dimension-hopping,
he is no different from any pleasant
stranger you might encounter on the street.
While some entities, like 507, behave
like a neighbor to the SCP Foundation,
others, like SCP-131, are more like house pets.
SCP-131 refers to a pair of creatures nicknamed
the “Eye Pods,” two teardrop-shaped creatures
about one foot high, one orange and one yellow,
with a single blue eye in the middle of each of
their bodies. Their intelligence has been compared
to common house cats, and they are very curious,
loving to roll around the facility and see what
everyone is getting up to. They appreciate
attention and affection and seek more of it
from those who they bond to, following them around
like a lost puppy. They may look strange at first,
but their behavior is downright adorable.
And as you may know from some of our other videos,
when certain deadly anomalies,
like SCP-173, escape,
they can storm in and save lives. So they’re
not only adorable, they’re adorable heroes!
Sometimes, an SCP with the best of intentions
can cause harm to Foundation personnel without
meaning to. This was the case for SCP-2337, a
male corn crake bird capable of vocalizations
loud enough to cause permanent hearing damage.
Though he possesses this ability, he has never
used it to cause deliberate harm while in
Foundation custody. Instead, he simply wants
to chat with the personnel, speaking in a language
similar to English. The bird, which responds to
the name Dr. Spanko, is very cooperative and
always excited to speak with research staff,
especially delighted when called by his name.
He may be a bit loud from time to time, but
who isn’t? He’s not malicious, just enthusiastic.
Sometimes an SCP’s good intentions are not
misinterpreted or inadvertently harmful, but
simply as helpful as they were meant to be.
Enter SCP-662, a small silver hand bell that,
when shaken, summons a short, well-dressed,
classic British butler named Mr. Deeds. Mr. Deeds
will address the ringer of the bell by their name
and title, and perform tasks for them. He is
extremely polite, and even when given a task
that he does not wish to or is unable to complete,
he declines with the utmost respect. His style
of friendliness may be more formal, but he’s good
company just the same. And we’ve heard he mixes a
mean - or in this instance, a “nice” - drink, too.
Many of the nicest SCPs to be around are similar
to pets, but very few were deliberately
intended to live in one’s home as a companion.
SCP-111 is an exception. 111 refers to a
species of invertebrates resembling snails,
also referred to as Dragon Snails. Unlike ordinary
snails, these creatures are warm-blooded, highly
intelligent, and capable of breathing fire. Though
they should be handled with care, hatchlings are
capable of imprinting on their owners much
like other baby animals, and likely would
make a lovely pet for a fireproofed household.
Unfortunately, they are all in Foundation custody,
so there is no way to find out for yourself.
Some of the previous SCPs in this video are
similar to ordinary pets, but SCP-529 actually is
an ordinary pet, with one small anomalous change.
SCP-529, or “Josie,” is a small
house cat with grey tabby markings,
and only half of a body. Don’t get upset! She
is not injured or in any pain. For some reason,
the rear end of her body, from tail to the
bottom of her ribcage, is simply not there.
The place where the cat’s body ends appears as
pure black to the naked eye, and absorbs light.
The area does not appear to be invisible, but
it is simply not there. In spite of this, Josie
experiences no adverse effects, moving around as
if the back half of her body were still there.
There are no containment procedures in
place for Josie, and she is allowed to
freely roam the facility, purring, rubbing
up against personnel’s legs for attention,
playing with balls of string and little mouse
toys, and begging for pieces of cheese as a treat.
Creatures like Josie the half-cat provide a
morale boost to those that encounter them,
but entities like SCP-5094 can provide material
benefits to the lives of those they meet,
and help them to make a change for the better.
SCP-5094, or Miss J, is the main character of a
children’s educational CD-ROM game called
Miss J’s Whiz Kidz Schoolhouse. Miss J,
who is unable to leave the computer
program, has only one interest:
educating others. She can teach a given student
about essentially any subject, including particle
physics and Cubist sculpture. She conducts
her lessons over the course of several days,
up to 30 hours in length, with breaks for meals
and trips to the bathroom sprinkled throughout.
Test subjects who studied with Miss J have
described her as the best teacher they have ever
had, and she helped a D-Class leave the Foundation
and begin a career studying criminal justice.
She even recognized a former student, now
a Junior Researcher at the Foundation,
and expressed delight at seeing how far he
had come since her first lesson with them.
Many of the friendlier SCPs have a great
deal of knowledge they are eager to share,
and one of the most eager out there is SCP-1867,
or Lord Theodore Thomas Blackwood. Lord Blackwood
identifies himself as a British explorer and
naturalist as well as a war veteran, which
is a bit perplexing considering that he is also a
neon sea slug measuring only 4.6 inches in length.
In spite of this, he enjoys telling anyone who
will listen, the tales of his past expeditions,
which he has been able to provide ample proof of.
Lord Blackwood is happy to provide entertainment
and engaging tales of adventure to anyone who
would like to listen to the stories of a sea slug.
If you’re interested in the company of Lord
Blackwood because of a fondness for stories,
then you’ll also want to hear about SCP-1230.
1230 is a simple unlabeled green hardcover book
with nothing strange about it, at first glance.
When it is opened, the phrase “a hero is born”
can be seen on the first page the reader looks
at, and the rest of the pages will appear to be
blank. The true anomalous effects of the book
do not kick in until the reader goes to sleep.
There, they will find themselves in a
fantastical world as the protagonist of their own
adventure story. The dream world feels real,
as real as the waking world, and the story is
tailored to the interests of the reader. In the
dreams, a bearded man in a green cloak appears,
known as the Book Keeper, and acting as the
voice of SCP-1230. He is helpful and kind,
providing guidance to the dreamers and attempting
to ensure that they have a wonderful time
in their dream. Just before the dreamer wakes
up, the man bids them a sorrowful farewell,
and asks that they “please visit again soon.”
It seems that the book and its keeper want
nothing more than to give readers an incredible
experience, and the chance to live out their
wildest dreams as the hero of their own story.
Speaking of objects that help people fulfill
their dreams, SCP-2203 devotes itself to
fulfilling romantic dreams in the waking world.
2203 is a standard “Love Tester” machine which,
upon use, dispenses a card with the name and
address of a person, as well as a bit of advice on
how to approach them. This person is intended to
be the soulmate of the subject, and, when subjects
approach their chosen person, they find that there
is an immediate spark. Test subjects who sought
out their assigned person have found either
a spouse, a lover, or a lifelong best friend.
It refuses to suggest matches to individuals
with a history of domestic violence,
indicating that its intention is to only make
matches that will be happy, healthy, and safe.
Many of these friendly SCPs display a strong
desire to help others however they can. Few show
this desire more strongly than SCP-2295. 2295 is
a patchwork stuffed teddy bear made from synthetic
fiber and cotton. When it is near a human who has
experienced major trauma to an organ, the bear
becomes active. It will produce scissors, white
thread, and sewing needles or a crochet hook,
and create a stuffed version of the ailing organ.
The damaged organ will, somehow, be replaced
with this new creation. It sounds as if
this is the start of a horrifying story,
but it isn’t. The stuffed organ will function
perfectly, defying all known laws of medicine
and science. The bear wants to help so badly
that, if there are no useful materials nearby,
it will use stuffing and fabric from its own body
to construct these organs. When the bear is unable
to help a subject, it will do whatever it can to
cheer them up and make them happy, and has even
been known to hold the subject and cry if there is
nothing else it can do. Above all, the bear simply
wants to help heal the hurt and the sick.
Without a doubt, the friendliest SCP that
the Foundation has ever encountered is
SCP-999, also known as the Tickle Monster.
999 is a large mass of orange slime that wants
nothing more than to play, socialize, and make
people happy. Its behavior has been compared to
that of a dog, enjoying the company of humans
and other creatures. Just touching its slimy
surface is enough to boost a person’s mood, and
the creature expresses special interest in people
who are unhappy or suffering from emotional pain.
It refuses to eat meat and goes out of its way to
prevent any harm to those around it, even taking
a bullet for a person to save their life. 999 is
such a delight to be around, that it even managed
to make the omnicidal rage of SCP-682 subside,
if only for a moment. Dogs might be considered
man’s best friend, but SCP-999 is giving them some
fierce competition for the role. Though, it would
probably want to be best friends with a dog, too.
And hey, if you want your own SCP-999 to cuddle,
make sure to check out scpswag.com to pick
up a Tickle Monster plush. It’s the next
best thing to having your very own SCP-999 to
cuddle whenever you need a little pick-me-up!
Now go check out “SCP-5031 - Yet Another
Murder Monster” and “SCP-999 and the Most
Wholesome SCPs” for more SCPs that’ll warm
your heart and put a smile on your face!